welcome to our review of truth or dare
distributed by Universal Studios do you
think I should post a review from a
Universal Studios movie John truth or
dare
dare I dare you to post review using
Universal Studios footage and then get
demonetised
that's a risk it is it is a risk
nowadays and the truth is it will get to
monetize it probably not over time I'm
actually hoping it does so I can
screenshot it and post it on Twitter and
like a day I did not hit her it's not
true it's bullshit I did not hit her
[Music]
truth or dare is directed by jeff wadlow
the man behind international assassin
movie Kevin James thing with whatever it
was called and kick ass - and kick ass -
which is interesting and he's now made a
Blum House horror film based around the
game truth or dare and in this film it's
haunted and it's life or death you can
die in the middle of the game and never
come back if you break the rules you die
if you don't answer the questions for
truth you die if you don't succeed in
your dare and you check it out you die
and you get taken over by this hilarious
derpy grin that haunts this movie and is
a curse to all of us
everyone in this film at some point does
their best impression of Willem Dafoe
and like you said along the way they
just make up the rules as they go two
truths and then one dare you can't do
more than three or four is it I don't
think the people writing the script knew
what they wanted to do so they just had
a crayon and they just filled in the the
blank spaces along the way so John and I
saw this film tonight and I think we
instantly had a reaction to it that was
kind of unprecedented when it comes to
horror films that we haven't really
experienced since last year yeah well
the first reaction was I wanted to
regurgitate the sour patch kids I was
eating but yeah this is the best worst
movie we've reviewed together since
bye-bye a man without a doubt why is it
every time we get together we just talk
about I've never I've never done a new
release as a hilarious atiba for fuck it
this movie is shit but it's fucking
awesome I laughed my ass off the whole
time this movie i don't know how
intentional it was to be funny and if it
wasn't intentional that's what makes it
so great I hope it was accidental
because it makes that it makes it that
much better so it opens with a snapchat
opening titles which apparently I was
looking into the the filmmaking process
the actors actually snapchatted and and
that's what became the opening title
sequence
all these friends are on a Spring Break
tour of Mexico and they of course go to
a bar listen to some really shitty
dubstep and then they get stuck in a
church somewhere with some random guy
who wants to play truth or dare with
them who basically
gets them stuck in this ring of death
where they all have to go from person to
person playing truth or dare and it goes
in a an order just like Ouija and all of
these films that revolve around some
game that a bunch of kids are playing
which by the way they're like 32 they
trying to be college kids yeah yeah this
reminded me of the modern-day equivalent
to final destination except the final
destination was entertaining because
people would get rollercoaster accidents
and trucks would explode and logs would
fly into there in this movie they just
play truth or dare
yeah and then they make stupid faces and
people die that is that's it that's the
summary to this who is it and I gotta be
honest I loved it okay it's the quality
of this film no but this is like a bye
bye man to me or any of those like
sleepwalkers so Stephen King sleep walk
there's any of these horror films that I
could watch again like I might actually
buy this and watch it again at a party
with friends really yes I mean it's I
don't like it I think I can watch it
again I really don't in the right
position if you dared me I could watch
it again that would be a tough tear yeah
that would be a tough there I hate films
that rely on modern-day social media
references movies based on Facebook or
Instagram
it just feels like this movie will be
dated in six months like friend requests
yeah it's just it really that's what I
hate and everyone in this movie did you
hate everyone every single character
there was not one character that I even
remotely gave a shit about no they they
were emotionally nuk they didn't care
about each other their best friends and
boyfriends would die and then six
seconds later they were just like well
that happened let's go get coffee or
something was incredible like I I was
trying not to be an asshole in the
theater because there were a few other
people no you heard
I was trying so hard to stifle it though
because I hate being that guy because
what if someone there was actually
really liking it fuck there's so many
scenes I was just dying inside that was
just like that's trying so hard not to
laugh okay so in the trailer a death
that that's shown in the trailer and
okay we're gonna get into some spoilers
if you've ever seen any of my hilarious
T reviews they are reviews of movies
that I find hilariously bad and I always
get into spoilers and so we're gonna
talk about spoilers with truth or dare
this is in the trailer though we get
this kid who's just like the asshole of
the movie he always wants to fuck
anything that moves
he gets dared at a bar to show his penis
that's part of the game and he gets up
he's like I wanna show you my business
it's on top of a pool table and he
chickens out it just and so because he
chickens out the game kills him how does
he how does he die he he slips and
basically smashes his head into another
table you die so after that all of his
friends get a text of this video of
their associate not really friend he was
sort of like an asshole to them but they
knew him dying the one kid watches it
and then like two minutes later he just
starts watching it again and he's just
like yeah I'm gonna watch my friend die
like it was a cat playing the piano or
something yeah like yeah that's okay and
that's the thing about this movie
throughout the entire movie every time
someone dies no one cares nothing
matters theirs knows there's no
consequences but I think the movie you
come to the conclusion that you don't
like anyone in this movie and you want
them all to die yeah and it's almost
like the the writers were kind of
banking on that like we want everyone to
not give a shit about any of these
people because they're just expendable
kids for for something to kill and and
the other thing about this film that I
just can't stand again I thought it was
funny okay it was entertaining in a
stupid way but like I could not stand
how obvious all of the cliches were like
now we're going to have the Google
research scene where they learn about
the past history of whatever this entity
is this has to be the research scene or
something like and bye bye man
she goes to a library and the librarian
gets like momentarily possessed or
something and then they go to a library
in this movie and she almost gets
possessed by it and that's the other
thing there's no true antagonist in this
film it's just the idea the concept I
needed an entity I needed something yeah
they they bring up some sort of demon
named kale --ax kale ixia that's right
and and it's he's in the movie for like
five minutes and at the very end just
reference that yeah you know you don't
see anything he just it's just a person
makes that stupid fucking face I guess
they thought that was very frightening
but to me every single time it happened
without fail I laughed my ass off it was
out of place and it was comical it was
it's the best way to describe it they're
trying to be intentionally scary but
every time they try their hardest it's
the funniest most hilarious part of the
entire movie it is and there's so many
sequences that build to nothing where
like for instance the end apparently she
figures out how to win and she tells her
her last friend like I you have to pick
dare she's like what if I pick dare it
might say something crazy she's like no
you have to pick dare so she's like fine
and she picks dare and the demon dares
her to shoot the protagonist but she
does and like there's a jump-scare noise
and because of that she shoots her
friend in the arm instead of like a
mortal wound there's never a
conversation like yeah just shoot me in
the arm she wants me to shoot if it
wants you to shoot me
it just happens and then that gets
scrapped and they just restart it and
literally infect the entire fucking
world she puts out a YouTube video
incorporating anyone who watches it into
the game she put out an atom bomb to
destroy everyone and in the beginning of
the movie when they first played truth
or dare in that abandoned church in
Mexico she gets asked a question if
aliens would come down here and would
you sacrifice all of us for everyone's
life in Mexico and she says oh I would
sacrifice our lives but by the end of
the movie she changed her tune a little
bit yeah she completely changed his
character he goes from like the good
girl
the one person who's doing everything
right that you're supposed to respect
and like you said she says I would
rather kill all of my personal friends
than the entire country of Mexico and
then at the end of the movie she puts
out a YouTube video infecting the entire
populace who watches it with the demon
imagine if he could do such a thing
putting out a YouTube video where he
could just kill everyone if they watched
a speak of the character is like you
said they're all cliche there's one
character she's the best friend of
Olivia the main character and every time
they have an argument or something bad
happens this happened three times
throughout the movie she gets angry and
always storms out of the room because
they did star whole care they didn't
know what to do with her character and
her character has this convoluted
backstory with her father committing
suicide and her father at one point
tried to like pull an American Beauty
with her best friend when he was drunk
and it's just they forced so many ideas
down your throat but they don't know
that how to actually execute any of them
to be believable once again if you
really break down this movie the ending
is based upon making a YouTube video to
kill humanity that is what happens how
can you even could could you even make a
sequel to that it's just it might even
be a kind of entertainment maybe like
the entire world is almost like truth or
dare like a post-apocalyptic wasteland
everyone's setting in circles playing
truth or dare yeah every single person
just walking around with that face like
that'd be amazing
I could see that I could watch it that
sounds even better make that Hollywood
please right now yeah and and that
backstory with the dad sort of comes to
life exciting outside of a restaurant
looking at her phone watching an old
video of her dad who's she's like oh I'm
making us some swordfish steak for you
honey and all of a sudden the dad in the
phone just goes like it just starts
talking to her like in the phone and
he's like I have a gun you should go get
that gun man she's just crying like dad
it's amazing it wasn't even necessary I
mean he could have just cut that story
out save 20 minutes of the movie and
just got to the point and I don't think
they even knew what the
ending to the movie was going to be when
they were writing it I bet money that
there are like four to five alternate
endings on the blu-ray at least yeah at
least I feel like it we got little
tidbits of each one of those in the
movie but they couldn't quite commit to
either I did actually feel like that now
that you mention it it felt like
multiple endings strung together because
if you watch like the final I guess
confrontation that occurs in this church
it does not make sense no the character
motivations for what occurs doesn't make
sense what we see happen doesn't make
sense
like they find out you're supposed to
find the person who started it cut out
his tongue say a chant seven times and
stick it in a pot a jar a jelly jar with
a skull face on it and it's like what
the kid starts cutting off his tongue
and of course it's pg-13 so you can't
really see any of that but the kid dies
before you really think it happened and
then you're like well can they just pick
up the tongue and put it in the jar or
does he have to do it the the entire
backstory to the demon doesn't make
sense there's there's nothing about the
ending that works no nothing not one
thing and by the end of the movie you
give up you give up and you're just
hoping something funny a bit to redeem
itself and it does yeah she makes a
youtube video she makes a youtube video
and it's it's great she makes this
YouTube video okay but you know what the
YouTube video gets a copyright strike by
Universal Studios it gets taken down
probably so in the end Universal Studios
say days everyone humanity all right
well you know that's better good job
Universal Zephyr well the other thing is
when everyone's watching this YouTube
video there's like people in like
England China across every continent
with landmarks behind them but you know
we both make youtube videos and the more
I think about that it's really
intriguing because I think if she was
just a random girl that made a YouTube
video it would have like two views right
so really it doesn't maybe no it doesn't
matter no I mean like what might happen
is she makes the video like to people
watch it yeah and then something
actually happens they spread it and then
they spread it yeah like the ring curse
tape-based oh yeah yeah so the same guy
who watched the video of his
friend died twice just to laugh at it he
really doesn't believe them he's at a
job interview and people are texting him
his friends are like it's real you have
to believe me what does he do he sends
them the poop emoji this guy is going to
college to be a doctor yes he also
looked like a Patrick Bateman vibe a
little times that's the vibe I was
getting yeah he seemed to not give a
shit about anybody or any or anyone he
was a sociopath he was he wrote
prescriptions for people somehow there's
there's never any explanation for how he
has like a prescription pad pamphlet
he's just like here you go here's a
prescription for vicodin or whatever and
they're just like thanks that's ok I
guess and you have it he has a pen that
says doctor on it yeah and then he goes
into some random job interview and stabs
himself and I'm like you just set the
poop emoji
what are you doing where's this movie
doing it doesn't it's not doing anything
you're just making stupid faces I love
it though yeah the script definitely it
felt like a student film it felt like a
18 year old kid wrote this when he came
home after a long night it blows my mind
that films like this get made and on a
serious note I mean it's depressing if
you really think about it kind of and
also I'm so tired of the trend of pg-13
horror films that have no style there's
no substance if this movie tried to be a
good movie that's fine PG can work for
that yeah the quiet place is pg-13
exactly a perfect example and I'm just
I'm tired of it Chris stupid faces
stupid people stupid movies within the
first 10 minutes man there's like three
someone's behind me jump scares yeah the
jump scares loud sounds like Wes Craven
made fun of that in scream guys in 96
someone's standing behind you going on
your shoulder and then you turn around
that's not scary it's never been scary
ever it did nothing and it was almost
distracting at times but also a attitude
the comedy aspect of it again there was
a few times where someone who's just
walk into a room like just casually
walking into a room and they play the
sound yeah
and then he would just say something and
then leave thanks man
I loved the funniest jump scare to me
was one of the characters was in front
of a vending machine the candy wasn't
falling he's in a hospital because one
of his friends of course is all fucked
up and everyone's dying and some old guy
in a bed just like walks up like right
behind him grabs him it goes like and I
was that was the best like that was my
favorite part yeah exactly
this movie needed to commit to that this
movie was holding back trying to be a
real movie which it couldn't be he
needed to go over the top of be crazy
and you would have had a better movie
because it knew what it was it was
self-aware so more old guys that are
dead in the hospital stuff yeah more of
that less of like random people in a bar
making that face and just walking up to
them and tapping them on the shoulder
yeah they're there yeah just dumb
characters that you don't like they're
stupid college kids that use snapchat
too much and the other thing is you
could tell that the writers were like
well we can't actually make this movie
unless we change the rules about truth
or dare because otherwise everyone would
just say truth over and over again and
get into some awkward situations we have
to have them be forced in some way to
say dare so you can only say truth so
many times before someone else has to
say a dare which is like this rule they
just throw in there for fun halfway
through the movie all in all truth or
dare is awful and terrible in every way
but really what were you expecting it's
you know it's a movie about truth or
dare where kids get together and the
game truth or dare is haunted by a demon
so in that aspect the movie was actually
pretty good
I don't agree no it was bad I'll
definitely watch it again though in at a
party with the right people and I'm like
you just enjoy this film because in a
lot of ways you'll laugh I don't want to
watch it ever again I would invite you
and I would be there obviously but I
would rather watch bye bye man yeah
before this because of the fluency where
the lady dies while driving down
please insert a clip so John what would
you give truth-or-dare
an F yeah an F it's it's a terrible
movie it was made as a cash grab for the
hopes of getting underage kids to watch
a bad movie but yet they will connect
with it because the characters use
social media and snapchat and that's
cultural references and I guess so yeah
yeah
I give it an F as well it's really
fucking bad but holy shit I laugh my ass
off so I mean this is my first ever new
release that I just decided to go
straight to the lair yosity mode because
I think it deserves it maybe see it's
one day on Netflix or if it's free on
Amazon Prime please don't waste your
money at the theater because then we
might get another one that being said I
wouldn't mind a sequel to see what
happens with this curse spread
throughout the popular I would like to
see that as well I'm curious how that
plays out that's what I want to know
well guys thank you so much as always
for watching this review and thank you
my buddy John for doing this review with
me you can check out his channel below
please do check it out you guys are the
best and as always if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]